hey you guys
look at the movie that we're talking
about today yeah
the town that dreaded sundown yeah
that's actually one of my one of my
favorite movie titles ever
yeah i don't know why there's something
about it that's very exciting again
charles b pierce charles b pierce the
most interesting thing about this movie
is the director
charles b pierce he's the dude that also
did the boggy creek
movies yeah and he's a trip you know
he's an independent filmmaker
from where was he texarkana or american
from arkansas
okay and he was trying to show those uh
hollywood boys that
that uh rednecks could make movies
swamp people could make movies which you
know
technically he did make movies this is
the best movie he's made
in terms of just quality and the story
it is like a slasher it is a slasher but
it's also a documentary at the same time
and it has elements of documentary in it
it
which i liked it because it made you it
kept reminding you that this was
something that actually did happen
even though certain ways that people got
killed and the way it ended was not
exactly the way
it happened but close close and it's an
entertaining movie
they took some yeah they took some
artistic license yeah
and the legendary jimmy clam is in it i
had totally forgotten
because i saw this movie a long time ago
yeah and we've talked about this
on various other uh matinee shows and
stuff but jimmy clem
is the guy that was in boggy creek too
and the legend continues he might have
been in the first boggy creek as well
because he tended to use like all the
same actors
and um jimmy klim is a hidden gem
of this guy's flip flicks he puts clam
in there
and clem he he he doesn't phone this
[ __ ] in
he's he's acting it's funny though he
uh he he comes across as a guy that
would probably be really amusing in real
life
yeah because you know i think he's just
playing himself like he's playing
himself i mean most of the people in
this there's a couple of kind of bigger
known uh
actors in the town that dreaded sound
down like mary wells who played um
or don wells rather who played marianne
on gilligan's island
and andrew prine who was in grizzly and
he was in like a [ __ ] ton of movies and
tv in the 70s
and he's in this as well playing one of
the cops but most of the other people in
the movie are
locals like detex arcana yeah and the
girl that played
marianne in this from gilligan's island
she's in it and she looks just like she
did in gilligan's island she's just
she's cute as a bug i don't know how old
she is
probably in her 30s maybe in about in
this movie yeah
but she looks young and cute and it's
good to see her in the movie and she's
she's one of the victims but she
survives yeah she plays uh
katie starks i think it was like uh the
last victory who didn't die she actually
yeah she
uh she went through hell and she made it
so she's kind of like a hero
in a way yeah i mean in real life
because
okay so i guess if you don't know the
town that dreaded sundown came out in
1976
and was based on the real life uh case
of the phantom killer of texarkana
otherwise known as the moonlight murders
which we did a show about a long time
ago
it's basically a case similar to son of
sam or zodiac
it's almost like proto-zodiac it
happened in 1946
like over like like a 10-week period in
1946
i i kind of i was comparing it to son of
sam because
he was getting peoples in lovers lanes
for a while but then he went into their
houses eventually too so he started to
do a little bit of dish raider type [ __ ]
yeah well it was just the one it the one
the last one that he did
uh was in somebody's house yeah and he
shot he actually shot through the window
he was
graduating to something and then he just
disappeared nobody was what nobody knows
what happened to him
the movie ends with a big scene of the
cops seeing him and chasing him down
and having the shooting at him through a
trait through it through a train that
went by
and then he slips away to give it kind
of dramatic ending but that's not what
happened in real life
in real life he just he committed that
crime advantage they never found him
yeah and it's still unsolved yeah um a
lot of the cops that worked on the case
they had their suspicions of who the
main suspect was who was a dude named uh
ewell swinney
but uh he was actually in prison for
other things car theft forgery that kind
of crap
and a lot of the cops that were working
on the case
thought that it was probably him he was
kind of like the main or the prime
suspect
but they never had enough um information
and i think honestly the scene in in the
town that dreaded sundown where they
catch that guy named eddie whatever and
like they say something about
car theft i think that was supposed to
represent
him yeah because like i said okay so
don't ever know though
no i don't it's it's too long ago
because like i said it happened in 1940s
and i you know i remember reading about
that that suspect you were talking about
and yeah he kind of did like look like
it could have been him
but it kind of matches up with other
cases
suspects like that appear in other
well-documented cases
and and sometimes it turns out that it
wasn't that dude he looked like it could
have been him but
it wasn't him so he was kind of like the
only serious suspect they had honestly
and
and you know from what i've known of his
he was a criminal but
i don't really know if he was the
phantom killer i have a strange
suspicion
or sneaking suspicion that it was
somebody that they never suspected
maybe it was a true phantom a guy who
was living a secret
fantasy life and maybe they came close
to
catching him or after that last one he
realized
maybe he after that lasting he realized
maybe he wasn't going to get his fix
that that it wasn't as fun as he
imagined it to be or it
wasn't as satisfying as he imagined it
to be so he just stopped doing it
which that has happened before yeah
serial killers have just
gone cold they're like uh they kind of
lose their
their their lust for it and they just
stop i do kind of like and they sort of
point this out in the movie as well that
that for a time they were pretty sure
that the that the phantom killer was not
just some dude that had wandered in town
they thought that it was somebody
local they thought it was somebody
around there yeah um who was kind of
like you said
sort of living a double life and
actually when this movie came out
uh it it has like a tagline on the
poster
and actually the dude that painted the
poster he got like a lot of work later
he did
i think he even did those original star
wars trilogy posters just saying it's
like the same artist
but there was a um there was a tagline
on the poster that said something like
uh you know the
the dude might still be lurking around
texarkana and
when the movie came out like the you
know the dudes that were in charge of
texarkana were like can we not have that
on the poster because it's like we
really don't like
you know the fact that people would
still be like think that they're still
creeping around
but they did actually they were they did
succeed in getting it taken off some of
the merchandising but not all of it
there's a chance
that this case could have been something
like the original night stalker where it
was a cop that was doing it all along
and that could have been that wouldn't
you might have been in the damn
police force that was do handling the
investigation because that's kind of
like an arsonist
that joins the damn fire department yeah
you know what i mean so they can see
fires and start fires and then go put
the fire out
you know you have dudes that are like
that they become cops because
they want to kill people then they want
to see the investigation
too they want to be part of it yeah they
investigate it's like a win yeah and
then all of a sudden he feels powerful
because he's in the group of cops and
he's seeing that he's fooling them all
from the inside so that would be like an
added thing so it may have been
something like that
what was the original night star what
was his real name d'angelo d'angelo
i thought it was a cop when back when we
were covering that case and what was it
a couple months later it turned out they
caught him
d'angelo and he was a cop yeah and it
just
so it might have been some i i have a
suspicion it might have been one of the
cops
yeah could have been which is maybe why
they never caught him because of the
kind of skills that he
showed although i will say that the way
that they kind of portray the cops in
this movie not all of them but we'll get
to the one in a minute but the way that
they portray the cops
in this uh movie uh it's not surprising
that they never got it but i know that
they probably weren't like
i think if it was one of the cops it
wasn't one of the main ones that was one
of the [ __ ] invisible cops on the
periphery
yeah who wasn't getting any attention
kind of you know that it was something
like that
yeah and they never suspected him so
all right so as we said charles b pierce
is from uh
texarkana arkansas although i think he
was living in shreveport louisiana
around the time that this uh was made
so he had made the legend of boggy creek
which was about
how do you say that is that the falc
monster or the fook
monster f-o-u-k-e folk
folk monster could be lots of different
i don't know i'm not from arkansas
but that's what the boggy creek movie
was about that came out in 1972
and he kind of got a lot of um you know
traction out of that
so he decided he was going to make a
movie about another
local story uh which was the
texarkana moonlight murders from the
1940s
now as i said they they have like an
opening narration
which i guess i mean the legend of boggy
creek is also kind of like a docudrama
like a documentary type thing and um you
know with
people being interviewed and [ __ ] but it
the the way that they do the narration
is almost because it's like texas
chainsaw massacre as well so that was i
guess it was just kind of all
in the zeitgeist which that happened
after though yeah yeah that came out in
74. that came out after boggy creek but
before this one
i think what it was it was a thing of
convenience yeah
all right first of all doing some voice
over
lends credence to the story because it's
based on something that really happened
so you can do it in the docudrama
style which kind of adds some scariness
to it
because in the audiences of the time
we're not as sophisticated as we are
today we know we grew up in those times
and the internet wasn't there so they're
seeing this case for the first time it
was hard to research stuff like this
so you could really scare them with kind
of like the official official voice
over like like the voice of authority
and
if you noticed it gave exposition so you
didn't have to
shoot certain things so you saved money
yeah
that was another thing and i will say
that it's i mean it's clear that this
movie is low budget yeah but it's
competently shot
yeah yeah and it's actually pretty
entertaining actually
i will say that some of the scenes of
the
phantom killer attacking some of the
people are actually really really well
done and actually
really kind of creepy kind of like
something about friday the 13th part two
yeah so they actually did that really
really well and like i said the the
whole baghead thing like
you know the the killer with the bag
over his head because you were saying oh
that's like
and friday the uh part two i said yeah
but
you know you could say that friday the
13th part two ripped off town that
dreaded sundown but i was like well the
actual
phantom killer back in 1946 had a white
bag over here
he was described by the survivors i have
a feeling
that friday the 13th part two was a
rip-off
of this idea of the town that drive
itself
yeah cause it's a very early slasher
they saw that move they saw this movie
you can
see it in the choreography and the way
they shot certain kills
and that bag on the head was a spooky
element they just
omitted one eye yeah instead of having
two eyes cut in a bag they just left
one yeah and the way they would shoot at
his face and you could see the eyes
it was a good idea and uh
friday the 13th copy in this movie i
think it was a good idea
they did the right thing because because
friday the 13th got more exposure than
this movie i believe
in those days yeah everybody's seen it
now but this was a limited release back
in those days i had never even heard of
this movie never seen it a little bit
yeah well they did a remake of it in
2014 which was well i don't even know if
it was so much a remake it was like a
meta
it was fictionalized but it existed in
the
universe where the murders had happened
and the movie had happened
and then it was almost like about a
copycat killer yeah but i was talking
about us growing up in the 80s
yeah i had never heard of this movie we
never saw it
alongside friday the 13th this movie was
forgotten
by us when we were kids yeah you know
what i mean it was kind of out of
circulation by the time we were old
enough to see it
and by the time cable came around i'm
sure it re-emerged on vhs
yeah i remember seeing the cover on the
yeah i don't remember if i saw it back
then though i think i saw it later like
maybe in the 90s
the closest thing i ever saw anything
like to this back in the early 80s was
friday the 13th part two yeah and uh i
would have liked this one too
or you know what i might have seen this
on tv because it did kind of make the
rounds of
like tbs or some channels like that like
i think back in the mid 80s maybe i want
to say
yeah maybe maybe even earlier than that
yeah so it might have kind of because i
you know i i do remember seeing bits of
it like off and on
so let's kind of talk about so if you if
you're familiar with the case of the
phantom killer which like i said we
covered on another show
it's basically happened in 1940s in
texarkana
and it was a killer that targeted
couples in lovers lanes like i said much
like it was like a proto-zodiac kind of
and this film follows the events
fairly accurately um the timeline's kind
of messed up i think they
they kind of start because like i said
it's very documentary like they're like
you know it's march
3rd like 1946 or whatever whereas
actually the first
attack took place in late february of
1946
those two um victims actually did
survive
and one thing that i thought was really
weird they added a few things
like they added that some of the victims
like the first
girl that was attacked they said she
wasn't raped
but in real life she was actually
sexually assaulted with a pistol
um you know like the you know the guy
like stuck a pistol up her vagina
um in the movie so but they didn't
really mention that in the movie but in
the movie they said she was covered with
bite marks and i'm pretty sure that
that's not accurate
so i don't know why they like changed
[ __ ] out and also this
this first scene they couldn't talk
about the pistol maybe yeah maybe not
mouse maybe not so they had to come up
with white miles
and then the fact too that um the first
attack of the guy that survived the guy
gets pulled out the window
the car window and that didn't happen
yeah and that looked like something out
of friday the 13th
that's what i'm like man this is like
friday the 13th
seeing that scene well and particularly
jason would have done it yeah the big
dude
yeah and he kind of in coverage wouldn't
he with a bag on his head
yeah or was it just jeans and a flannel
shirt it was just jeans and like a kind
of shirt yeah it was similar
like yeah yeah similar image of jason
from friday 13 part two
before they put the hockey mask on it
yeah i liked it i liked it i thought it
was cool
actually the guy that played the phantom
in this his name was bud davis
and he was actually a stunt man and uh
he was
a stunt coordinator and like some big
movies later he did like inglorious
bastards with quentin tarantino he did
castaway forest gump
so he did a bunch of like you know he
went on to like kind of a big career
which was well this movie ends it ended
up in retrospect being a being occult
classic
it wasn't at the time though yeah yeah
now the only thing okay now here's what
i'm going to
get into well you know going back to
what we said about some of the kills
seeming like friday the 13th kills
and like i said it's very strange they
changed everyone's name
and some of the people like the cop that
gets brought in that they call lone wolf
um there actually was a texas ranger
whose nickname was sloane wolfe that
they brought in on the case
but his his name was otherwise different
he had a different last name so
he was kind of an amalgamation so some
of the cops are amalgamations of a
couple of people
um so they did kind of try to get and
like i said the victims are pretty
accurate they changed all their names
just i guess so they wouldn't get in
trouble although that didn't uh
end up helping them in the end because
you have to think when this movie came
out
it was only 30 years after the crimes
had happened and the
victims were young they were usually
teenagers or in their 20s
so a lot of the um relatives of the
victims were still alive
and a couple of them were not super
happy about uh
the way that the movie portrayed them
uh i think one of the victim's brothers
actually sued charles b
pierce um for for uh
you know for various things because of
like the way that his sister was
portrayed in the movie even though her
name was different
uh but i don't think he won i think he
was looking for like 1.5 million or
something like that but let's talk about
the scene with the trombone because i
feel like
you can't talk about the town that
dreaded sundown without talking about
the [ __ ] trombone kill
which like i said is very very much like
some [ __ ] that jason would do yeah
kinda i guess so later on yeah like like
in a later friday yeah like
five six it almost seems almost like a
freddy move
yeah it does a little bit it's kind of
probably the movie suffered because of
this scene i didn't think it was i
didn't think it was a credible
well charles b pierce got a lot of flack
for it at the time because uh you know
i thought it was too goofy yeah you will
probably not be surprised to know that
that was not how
that victim was murdered she actually
didn't even play
the trombone she played a saxophone and
they did find
like uh her saxophone later because she
had been coming from a band performance
at a vfw not a prom like in the movie
um but they actually they didn't find
her saxophone in its case until about
six months later like it was in a field
like near where she'd been killed
but she was not um stabbed with a
trombone
yeah and uh they did ask charles b
pierce it's like why what possessed you
to like put that in the movie because
it's kind of
goofy and it's really not respectful
toward like the real girl that was
actually killed
that's why they changed all the names
who yeah but it's like like i said that
he still kind of got in trouble but he
didn't get
um you know he got sued but he
still won because he you know i don't
know it's like he made a big deal about
saying this is a true story
but then he changed like all these
really bizarre details i can kind of
understand why though
yeah i mean he's he's trying to
trying to be respectful to the families
by not bringing up the person's name
and saying it is this this is what
happened to your kid that's
that's yeah he's trying to avoid that
and he's trying to avoid lawsuits
so he's fictionalizing the the murders
in there and he's changing the names to
protect the innocent was a little
[ __ ]
phrase they used to use that was on drag
dragnet
changing their names to protect the
innocent yeah that's what they're doing
it just was i feel like that's kind of
the most infamous scene yeah
um even though like i said it's it's not
accurate and but
but some of this [ __ ] like i said the
the last murder which was uh
virgil and katie starks were their real
names uh that wasn't what their names
were in the movie
but that was almost entirely accurate at
least from what i remember the case
where
you know the dude like shot the husband
through the window like and just killed
him he was sitting in his chair
and then shot uh the wife she ran to
call the police and
it shot her in the face and like knocked
all her teeth out and then she like ran
but she got away
yeah the the woman that they showed in
the movie getting killed by trombone
in reality i think she got killed by
didn't he beat her to death the baseball
bat
i can't remember she might have gotten
stabbed or because he
um the phantom killer used different
methods
he shot a lot of the victims some of the
victims he
beat um you know with
tire irons bats like you know blunt
objects things like that i think a
couple of them he stabbed
um some of them it was like multiple but
he did not kill anybody with a knife on
the end of a trombone so
i'm just saying i'm just saying that's
probably like the most infamous scene
now so let's talk about as fairly
accurate to
real life as this movie is other than
like i said there's the whole chase at
the end
where the two cops are like shooting at
the phantom killer because he's just in
the middle of the day hanging out in the
in the you know woods or whatever like
with the mask on
which i thought was very funny so but
they're like shooting at him under the
train and stuff yeah that didn't happen
the cops never
saw him the only people that saw him as
far as i know
were the victims that lived they're the
ones that said with the white bag over
the head and everything
so even though it tried to do that and i
feel like it almost was doing
like a serious like a docudrama kind of
feel to it which was good you know like
i said it was almost kind of like a
police procedural which
you know seemed respectful but then for
whatever inexplicable reason
charles b pierce decided he was going to
put himself in the movie
as a completely fictional character who
was like a patrolman right
i can't really even remember what his
character's name was all that other than
spark plug that was his nickname
and he puts himself in there as
essentially
a low-level cop who's a complete and
utter [ __ ]
and he's like the comic relief and it
just seemed
like so tonally
strange and unnecessary because it
seemed like he was trying to make a
fairly
you know um respectful movie about the
crimes
and then he inserts himself in there and
like this goofy
like he drives like an idiot um there's
one
like three minute long scene where he
gets in the car he's driving you know
lone wolf around
and he's like oh i forgot the keys to do
and then there's like this goofy ass
music and then he goes walks all the way
back to the police station all the way
like looks for the keys it takes forever
and it's trying to be in his own movie
as much as possible well he did that in
boggy creek too
like i said if you see boggy creek 2 and
the legend continues that's
he wrote himself as like the main
character in that one that's that's
really when he becomes interesting
those movies and that and i mean at
least that movie was about like a
bigfoot monster
so it wasn't about like real people that
got murdered and it's kind of the same
kind of tone
where it's kind of a pseudo documentary
you know trying to
get you to suspend your disbelief and
think that well back in those days i
remember you know i was a kid
bigfoot bigfoot type creatures were a
very strong possibility
the population wasn't as dense back then
we didn't have
satellites that could track down
individual body
signatures of people and game there
might have been a possibility that there
is
be a something like a bigfoot not in
that area though
not in the boggy creek area roads are
running everywhere
yeah i mean you know you know all you
gotta do is walk long enough in any one
direction you're gonna hit a road
yeah within you know within 20 30 miles
so there's just it's just not open
wilderness
so if anything like that were to exist
to be up in washington state or up in
canada in places where people never set
foot but
i mean but okay so like i said i don't
mind even though
the comic relief in the boggy creek
movies is
not funny in the way that they intended
it maybe
i just feel like the the choice for him
to just insert himself as like the lone
comic relief character in a serious
otherwise serious movie about a series
of real murders that happened
is just baffling to me and the fact that
he
you know that like i said there's that
whole interminable scene of him like
losing the car keys there's like um
just that one scene the one scene where
um which actually did happen in real
life where they were trying to bait the
killer
by having you know undercover cops like
out in lovers lanes and stuff
so of course they have like this wacky
scene in the town of dreaded sundown
where some of the cops like dress up as
women
and you know they go out and sit in the
car so there's like this bizarre scene
where charles b pierce in drag is
sitting in a car with jimmy clem
and they're just like talk and he's and
jimmy clem is like laughing and then
he's like squeezing his tit
it's just like the most arkansas thing i
i totally understand it
he's the reason why he wrote himself in
there doing all that
crazy [ __ ] is he's making a very kind of
novice
mistake but he's making this mistake
because
of the times in which he is making this
movie the era
in which he is making yeah this is a
subject matter
that is basically taboo in the time that
this came out this would have been a
cutting-edge slasher movie
disturbing kind of immoral to the
average
older person of the time yeah a person
in their 40s and their 50s would not
accept this movie they just wouldn't
they wouldn't see this [ __ ]
they would they'd go that's terrible
this is like
like making a snuff film so what he's
doing he's
inserting himself as a clown to try to
bring comedic relief and
levity to the movie yeah trying to tell
the audience
of his era that this movie is not to be
taken
seriously but on the other hand he's
telling you to take it real [ __ ]
serious yeah seriously without with with
the over um
the overdubs you know you know with the
voiceovers yeah
and you know like a documentary so he's
trying to offset that
um yeah i guess with all that clown now
is that was that a
good artistic decision no
no no it was definitely not pick one or
the other
he's just trying to hedge his bets is
what he's trying to
do i think that he's just trying to give
plausible deniability to the movie yeah
i mean one
he wanted to be in his own movie um but
he's like well i don't wanna
look like arrogant so i'm gonna put
myself in there as an idiot that's one
thing
and then the second thing like you said
it's like oh this is such horrible
subject matter
because as i said when this came out a
lot of locals were in it
you know this was still in living memory
like a lot of people all their relatives
were still alive and they would have
been
watching it and they and he knew that
they were going to be watching it
so you know i can see why i just think
it was like um bad
artistic decisions it was just not the
the way to go and and i know that in the
early 70s too because i feel like didn't
um
like uh you know some other movies that
came out in the 70s that were like
otherwise
i'm thinking maybe of like last house on
the left or something like that
where it had these really strange like
oh keystone cop kind of like oh we're
gonna put some comedic relief in here
because otherwise
um you know to like lessen the tension
and i'm gonna say i mean horror and
comedy
they go well together but you need a
real deft hand
yeah to pull that off and you end up
with evil dead or bubba hotep
yeah it's like and those are successful
or sean of the dead or something like
that
but i feel like a lot of times when it
gets attempted
it falls flat on its face you just
drafted it in there
yeah this grafted some comedy onto a
horror movie he should have left all
that out it would have been a much
darker movie
but it would have been it would have had
like a very pretty even tone throughout
it yeah because it was very serious
otherwise
and as i said the shots i mean the
scenes the sequences where the murders
took place were actually really really
well done i thought they were really
effective
without the comedic relief it probably
would have been taken a little more
seriously
on an artistic level in the movie
probably would have gotten a little more
notoriety i think
it could be i mean because it would have
gone down as kind of like of
the first [ __ ] friday the 13th type
movie
that's what i think it would or an early
version of an american one you know
something like that probably i like
halloween maybe
i mean you could argue though that the
fact that
the character that the uh you know comic
relief in it was so egregious
and add that to like the trombone kill
yeah maybe that's what maybe
made people remember it like you know
maybe
counter-intuitively i'm not really sure
a trombone idea just wasn't a good idea
well like i said it's not only
disrespectful to the victim
but it was also just dumb like why he
was trying to be edgy
we're going to take this you know this
killers has fun with his victims and
we're going to take this you know
it's going to and it just just it was
just a bad idea
if you're going to have he could have
come up with something better than that
yeah because the trombone is an
inherently goofy instrument yeah
and he was being kind of goofy with it
yeah because he was like oh gotta get
you yeah you gotta get it
yeah you know what i mean it's like i
don't know undercut the menace a little
bit yeah
i have to say i had forgotten about this
as well but that the girl that gets
killed with the trombone
she was in boggy creek too as well okay
i don't know if she was in the first one
she was remember she was one of the two
hot girls
okay that i just i didn't recognize her
at first because like i said this is a
period piece it's set in 1946 even
though it was
made in the 70s um and i didn't wither
with her
40s hair and makeup i didn't recognize
her but as soon as i heard her voice i
was like oh that's that chick from
boggy creek too because i've seen boggy
creek too because it was on mystery
science theater i've seen it about a
million
times but uh yeah so this movie
as i said it's sort of like i don't know
if i'd go so far say it's so like a lost
classic or anything like that i don't
know if i'd go as far as save as a
classic but
it did a lot of things that were if if
maybe it wasn't the first time to do
them but it was like very unusual at the
time
um i feel like it had a lot of slasher
tropes before that was really a thing
um i know black christmas had come out
two years before so it wasn't completely
unprecedented
and um you know texas chainsaw massacre
had come out two years before
too but it was one of the first ones to
do this sort of serious docudrama
um kind of thing and it was sort of one
of the ones i know texas chainsaw
massacre you know said it was based on a
real story it was based on ed geen but
it was very very loosely
very loose very very loosely based i
mean to the point where it's like not
really no um you know and psycho was
sort of based on ed gein again
very very loosely but i think this was
kind of one of the first films if not
the first film that was actually
tried to be accurate to an actual set of
murders
yeah you know and tried to take it
seriously you know notwithstanding
the ridiculous comic relief that they
really shouldn't put in there although i
still
i laughed my ass off at that scene of
charles b pierce and jimmy clem in the
car
yeah with that and him like squeezing
his titty yeah and you could tell that
like jimmy clem was like just laughing
and he
you know they should have done it had
lived yeah that's what i thought i
thought it was
because he was just like cracking up and
they weren't even like making an attempt
to like
do another take or anything yeah
jimmy clam from what i can see he was a
natural clown
he was he was funny oh yes and he had
like a big like hh holmes mustache in
this movie
i don't know anything about his
background he might have been a local
legend
for being a clown that's probably what
you know what it wouldn't surprise me
because like i said he was in boggy
creek too as well playing crenshaw
like he was that mountain man yeah yeah
that's his greatest role
that was his greatest role i look at
this movie as an early
a very competent early slasher
especially american tile
style slasher i mean the italians were
already on this by this time
but as far as the american style and
it's southern
um which is very good for being a
southern product very good
yeah this is not something from
hollywood and it it was better than a
lot of hollywood b
movies yeah i mean it's low budget but
it's actually stopped pretty well pretty
good i thought
and they were they took it seriously um
but i think some of the local politics
about
offending families and trying to bring
some levity to it
i think artistically that was not a good
decision
by today's standards back then it might
have been something that he had to do
by necessity because because of the
local politics
with the families and stuff yeah he's
trying to
settle everybody down and hey don't take
it so seriously we're changing the name
to protect the innocent yeah yeah
it was like that um i think
enjoyable movie to watch it is enjoyable
and they actually
shot it in texarkana where the actual
murders happened
and texarkana uh doesn't actually look
that different than it looked when this
movie was shot
do you know i think still to this day
they show this movie every halloween
in the in that park in texarkana
had i seen this in the early 80s
alongside halloween
or alongside friday the 13th one and two
i would have put it right there with
them uh although
probably the 13th hat was had a lot more
more of a sexual element had real cute
girls in it getting killed
and probably gorier a little bit gorier
but it would have been
totally kind of kind of the same just as
similar
i would i would have been spooked by it
yeah and like i said that one scene
where you know the
where he shoots that one guy and like
that other chick is like getting stabbed
or whatever that was like actually a
legit creepy scene i thought it was like
pretty horrific
had it not had the comedy in it this
this director may probably could have
gone on to
to do a long series similar to friday
13th
kind of in the way that the guy who did
um uh
phantasm um yeah don cosgrelli yeah
it could might have been something
similar to that but i think because of
the flaws of the film
i think it the concept didn't have
staying power in other words it was also
about
one case yeah you couldn't really
continue it
which maybe had he not made it about a
case he could have made a continuing
franchise
but had he done that it wouldn't have
been about the location he lived in yeah
and i mean i do something he's trying to
do stories that are local
that are local which is cool yeah it's
good that's actually a good concept
yeah trying to bring southern culture to
the mainstream as much as he can
and trying to use local legends and that
was his
that was his uh that was that was his
strategy
yeah which i guess it worked i mean he
made [ __ ] a total of four of these
four movies three of them were bigfoot
movies
and uh he made some other movies too but
i think those are like kind of his best
known ones yes
one of them one of the bigfoot movies is
lost it was scrapped and then
redone it again yeah i mean it might be
it might be out there somewhere but i've
actually never seen it i've only seen
the first one which came out in 1972 and
then the third one which is actually
called foggy
we could probably dig it up i could
probably dig it up yeah but like i said
he made some other ones too but
he and i think he worked on other movies
too i think
i think i could be wrong i think he
worked on he was like a set decorator on
outlaw josie wales oh okay i think no he
died in uh 2010
okay i think so he's yeah he's been dead
a while all right but um
yeah how do you not like try to be a
goofball in some of his movies i think
you'd have a little more staying power
maybe
yeah because i just feel like that was
kind of like i said it's fine in the
boggy creek movies because it's about a
[ __ ]
you know yeah sasquatch monster yeah but
if you're gonna talk about like real
people that got killed then had he taken
the humor out of this
it probably would have been a movie that
fengoria would have talked about
and you know maybe upped the up the gore
a little bit more
yeah it probably would have been
something that the slasher scene would
have really remembered
although they did talk about it off and
on i remember i remember talking about
i remember hearing this because it
wasn't one of the [ __ ] main ones back
in in the early 80s that
you that came up a lot yeah that's true
but yeah uh so
that's town that dreaded sundown from
1976 like i said they did a remake in
2004 well sort of a remake
which actually wasn't too bad i saw it a
while back i don't remember that much
about it but
it that's a completely fictional story
it's not anything about the
moonlight murders but you know if you
want to check that out you can we
actually watch this for free on youtube
so if it's still there then you can go
check it out as well i think it might
also be on amazon prime depending on
where you are
but yeah that'll do it for this movie
retrospective and we will see you guys
on the next one
bye
you